now the only scheduled witness for this
day as the former US ambassador to
Ukraine who says she was the target of a
smear campaign led by President Donald
Trump Murray Ivanovich arrived on
Capitol Hill just a few minutes ago and
she is the third witness to speak
publicly about the events surrounding
Trump's now famous phone call would the
Ukrainian leader in July
he's accused of threatening to withhold
military aid on this Ukraine
investigated his political rival Joe
Biden
Jovanovic is a career diplomat and an
anti-corruption advocate last month she
told the inquiry about efforts by trumps
lawyer Rudy Giuliani to publicly
discredit her she said a senior
Ukrainian official had warned her to
watch her back
now Giuliani had accused her of
undermining the president before Trump
dismissed her in May in just a moment
our White House correspondent Kimberly
halket will join us but first let's go
to Heidi show Castro she is outside the
hearing room on Capitol Hill we have a
pretty good idea Heidi of what mr.
vanovech will say so what kind of
questions are we expecting from both the
Democrats and Republicans sure will from
Democrats Elizabeth were expecting them
to elicit from Murray Ivanovich the
story that really paints the backdrop to
the bribery accusations that President
Trump is now facing that are at the
center of this impeachment inquiry as
you said we have heard from her
previously in the closed-door session
we've seen the transcript so much of
what she says actually may not be new to
the investigators but the fact that she
is speaking them now on camera is what
Democrats are hoping that the American
public will take away as the story comes
to life and what she's expected to say
is that back in early spring she was
made aware of this irregular channel of
US foreign policy at that time it was
headed by Trump's personal attorney Rudy
Giuliani and she has said that he was
meeting with ukrainian officials
and that the context of this was Ukraine
had an incoming president which Marie
Ivanovich said she had a lot of faith in
she was fighting corruption from the
previous administration but elements of
that previous Ukrainian Ilyn
ministration were meeting with Giuliani
trying to curry favor and to do that she
says that they were spreading lies about
her potin why is that she knew President
Trump was sensitive too they said that
she was against Trump that she was
advocating for his impeachment and
apparently Giuliani took those
statements back to his boss the
president and eventually that led to
Jovanovic is a ousting in may after more
than 30 years of service in the foreign
service to the US now she was out of the
picture by that Elizabeth and that is
something that Republicans will surely
point to she wasn't present for the
future events of the later events that
unfolded including the accused quid pro
quo from the president toward Ukraine
and you'll very likely see the line of
questioning from Republicans focused on
that Heidi thank you for that for now
that is Heidi Joe Castro live on Capitol
Hill let's bring in our White House
correspondent Kimberly Hellcat president
Trump has ridiculed Maria vanovech in
the past Kimberly and he's been busy
tweeting his thoughts about the inquiry
now yeah ridicule to say the least the
US president referring to her in fact as
bad news was the phrasing that I believe
he used and he didn't say just once he
said it multiple times so he really
doubled down on what essentially the
investigators on Capitol Hill are trying
to highlight throughout the former US
ambassador to Ukraine's testimony and
that is that there was this very broad
and sweeping a smear campaign if you
will that was first put in place by the
president's own personal attorney
Rudolph Giuliani highly irregular
considering he's outside normal
diplomatic channels and ultimately that
was such an effective smear campaign
that it led to her firing and also who
engaged allegedly and this was the u.s.
president so
went to the highest levels this is
something that we are seeing as these
the house investigators work to
carefully craft their argument as they
work towards the articles of impeachment
now you're right the US president has
been tweeting he often tries to set the
news cycle early in the morning here in
Washington this is no exception he is
targeting Nancy Pelosi the House Speaker
trying to discredit these proceedings
Kimberly thank you for that for now
that's Kimberly halket live in
Washington DC